nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui pour
cette fameuse vidéo serait d'horreur à
plusieurs commentaires et vous
aujourd'hui c'est pas moi qui vais
raconter des histoires et c'est pas des
témoignages que j'ai vu sur internet
c'est des histoires que vous avez vécu à
liszt clara et sociales ont vécu
plusieurs trucs dans leur vie creepy ils
vont raconter le truc le plus creepy à
vos yeux vous avez que c'était lui le
plus creepy way out avec une petite
histoire c'est le seul
c'est l'unique c'est l'unique et je ne
connais pas les histoires j'ai entendu
parler à une époque de ses analyses mais
j'ai hâte de la découvrir en détail on
tente aujourd'hui j'avais envie de faire
évoluer le format contex invités et
surtout je suis content parce que pour
une fois après avoir attendu une
histoire je vais pouvoir poser des
questions réagir les votes des
spectateurs là pour une faute voilà
exactement mais est-ce que je ne compte
pas faire habituellement je peux pas
poser des questions aux personnes
puisque c'est des trucs qu'ils ont posté
à deux ou trois ans sur les dites là
croyez moi mais vous mangez un ta
question que les trois allers le mode
noalys tuer la 1re c'est parti pour
l'histoire de alice vraie histoire
qu'elle a vécue
attention pour rassurer les gens lèvent
la main sur l'année - et on dit je ne
dis même que les choses mais que je
n'excluais que j'ai vécu oui voilà très
bien quand c'est parti ok il ya un an
l'été c'était la canicule
j'étais allé faire un barbecue en
banlieue du coup je suis rentré tard
relativement tard chez moi vers 2 heures
du matin je vivais avec ma coloc pauline
qui n'avait pas vu rentrer une heure
plus tard quatre heures du matin il ya
pauline kee meute aucun rapport et qui
me réveille avec une phrase un problème
qui me dit il ya un homme dans la maison
juste ça quand on travaille avec quatre
heures comme ça enfin tu étais pas
lucide tu comprends pas feinte et est
dans les vapes tu comprends pas du tout
ce qui se passe et moi je pensais
qu'elle me faisait une blague un peu en
mode élire un homme dans les maisons en
mode c'est qu'il donne dans la maison où
je sais pas je pense qu'elle parlait de
son mec je comprends pas du tout de quoi
elles me parlent et je lui dis mais nous
on n'y a personne enfin est maudit mais
c'est ici là il ya un homme dans la
maison à côté de moi est en fait en gros
mois donc pause effet près on gagne le
surnom dont le soutien est elle me dit
mais tu l'entends pas tu vois pas il à
côté de moi et commence à devenir fois
là on l'a nommé dis moi que tu vois
l'homme qui est là devant ma tête tu
vois et là effectivement j'entends un
mec qui parle imparfaite anglais donc je
sais que déjà je pensais que c'était le
mec de poly n'y avait que lui qui
pouvait
qui pouvait être là et je skie ne parle
pas du tout anglais je comprends pas tu
vois est tellement décontracté le mec
dit juste guys and just rocking faute de
keys to get out parce que tu peux pas
sortir de chez moi sans clé il n'y a pas
de poignées en fait georges où sont tes
clés j'aimerais sortir donc le mec prend
les clés il sort comme ça ils descendent
mais vraiment médecins dimanche quoi et
et du coup je crie à pauline mais
celui-là parce que moi je n'étais pas
bien je ne pouvais pas me lever la gomme
ça j'allais déjà les pentes trop de
revenus pour ci lui le genre demande lui
qui s'était quand même assez drôle parce
que j'entends des prix dans les
escaliers et juste le mec se retourne
très décontracté lui sourit midi dans
thoiry et ce mec c'est ni un pote à toi
c'est rien ça et il est dans la pâte
apparaît en pleine nuit et vous dit non
mais juste et plus je m'en allais voilà
je cherche juste à sortir et la deuxième
c'est comment donc pauline remonte les
escaliers échéant mais qu'est ce qui
vient de se passer enfin comment il est
rentré et il me dit par la fête faut
savoir que j'habitais au deuxième étage
et c'est vraiment très très haut et
enfin c'est un pro tu vois c'est un
ninja j'espérais fin c'est moi qui fais
un combat
bref en gros elle pensait que c'était
moi qui étais qui était rentré un peu
pourri ou je sais pas quoi et qui feinte
qui peint on se fait vraiment
fréquemment des blagues et du coup
élément important pour rire elle dit à
yves beach enfin en pensant que c'est
moi elle ouvre la mort en disant à
bitche et là il tombe sur un mec nous
donne là il commence à répondre en
anglais parce qu'il a cru qu'elle est
anglaise parce qu'elle dirait beach en a
eu un la prochaine manche et le mec au
début il lui dit i'm looking for hope to
see après il lui dit i'm just want you
can host encore c'est une idée truc
contradictoires elle continue lui dire
mettez quitté qui est il répond pas là
où on a eu de la chance c'est que il
n'avait pas tout à fait le profil du mec
qui te fais ce qui te faisait flipper
dans le sens où il avait notre âge
en fait pas bon rob sur lui et tout bien
bien habillé ah bon un peu style ça
c'est non mais ça c'est un roc drogue
direct qui croient tapote elle a crû de
bulletins météo qu'elle est rentrée avec
un mec du coup moi premier réflexe
georges appelle les flics et au bout de
deux secondes je vois en fait la lumière
bleue genre à ma fenêtre lui ils sont
déjà là trop bizarre comment ça se fait
qu'il songe à la fin il s'est passé
trente secondes quoi et je vois qu'ils
ont attrapé le mec et qui a déjà une
voiture il ya déjà des gens rassemblés
en bas et tout
au très efficace quand même c'est mieux
que tout ce que j'ai lu mais attention
rien dit et en gros on descend il ya une
entreprise de vigiles très pratique et
en gros le vigile raconte que il a vu le
mec en fait monter chez nous et que du
coup il l'a enfin il a cramé direct et
qui lui a dit tu descends et c'est le
truc important dans cette histoire à
comprendre c'est que quand le mec qui
arrivait chez nous il s'était déjà fait
cramer c'est pour ça qu'il voulait
sortir ils devaient zassa de la fenêtre
il était comme ça on ne trouve pas de
chez ma cousine et c'était le meilleur
moyen sans forcer voilà est en fait le
truc c'est qu'est ce qui se serait passé
si vous n'avez pas vu assez moi c'est la
question qui revient donc tout les bons
d'expérience - qui lui et les gens qui
ont écouté beaucoup d'histoires comme ça
ouais soit ils venaient pour te mater
dormir mais ce qui est des arbres mais
c'est une vraie passion chez les gens
soient ils venaient pour faire des
choses horribles donc pas parler plein
de petits détails
si tu veux niveau profiling de comment
ce mec était ok vin du coup on a eu
accès à son sac à dos pour vérifier que
qu'il avait rien volé si tu es jeux
enfin c'est qu'on mélange sac à dos qui
s'est mis en mode le tupperware non mais
ça c'est pendant là c'est vraiment jean
michel aulas c'est pour ça aussi que les
flinders bay a le profil n'y a pas le
profil fin ils ont du mal à penser
vraiment que ce mec pouvait l'être à
comprendre que ses intentions étaient
pas eu il croyait vraiment ces espèces
de petits changements soudains pour nous
c'était évident que c'était justement un
mec un peu double face ce qui est
notable c'est que dans study ya plein de
points communs avec beaucoup d'autres
témoignages
en fait souvent c'est ça que rim avec
des gens qui vivent des trucs comme ça
il ya beaucoup de moments où ils sont 0
pris au sérieux par les gens sensés et
aider là dedans sans cesse qu'il faut
censé rappeler à l'orgue l'autre pour
plus jamais qu'ils refassent ça parce
que même si vous avez réussi
physiquement le préjudice moral il est
énorme bond très bien raconté incroyable
waouh annonce que je dis dans les scènes
ça arrive il s'est certes sur satan
c'est juste pour ça pas un truc là je
dis si le maigre au regard de cette
vidéo la vraie mais crois moi quand les
compteurs à 10,3 me attendus
tu crois que c'est ton tour alors c'est
pas du tout
truc moi c'est un truc le plus fou au
sens où il ya vraiment de la folie dans
l'histoire comme ça qui arrive il ya
quelques années
plus spécifiquement à mon père savard
ses comptes armes qu'il a un cabinet
médical qui au rez-de-chaussée d'une
maison dont la porte est ouverte
du coup quand gainey est ouvert à la
rentrée durant comme tu veux te rendrais
personnes fermé la porte puisque ben
voilà il a accueilli que ma cousine et
de ses trois enfants et son mari qui
vivaient au deuxième étage et donc du
coup un jour là je suis à fond dedans la
gestion est donc là j'ai le plan et tout
d'un coup je vais attaquer un jour mes
cousines prend cet hymne de l'ange pour
faire la laissiez de ses enfants en
premier étage et puis on entre temps
elle décembre la secrétaire lui dit
bonjour la discute non non pierre
romande parler dans la lingerie est là
elle capte que dans l'appartement il ya
plein de trucs qu'on changeait pas chez
elles mais aux premiers il ya plein de
trucs qu'on change et des trucs super
chelou genre les photos de famille ce
sont en face contre terre passe contre
meubles faits peu de mon père elles sont
toujours droite y compris celle de mon
grand frère qui ressemble beaucoup à mon
père et en plus de ça il ya des photos
d'une meuf genre qui se sont ajoutés aux
autres
elle s'est dit mais un truc chelou c'est
ma femme me dit quelque chose et il ya
les langes dans son étendue partout dans
l'appartement personnes vivaient dans
attend c'est quoi au premier étage raven
moyens et acheter un appart gens
reviennent en fait en gros c'était une
grande maison m du coup les deux étages
du dessus ça a été transformé en un
parti auquel original vie tout en euros
et au premier il y avait personne sont
ok ok donc je suis dit ok je vais faire
le tour de l'église mankell regardant
chaque pièce avec fini rien ne tient
rien elle va dans le salon et la caisse
qu'elle voit ses volumes affiliation
comme ça le regarde on essaie de lui
parler tu à ce que pareil que tu vois ça
tu sais plus comment réagir
j'ai choqué donc à fait vous ça va enfin
bon jour on veut pas de réponse rien
regard vide pareil tu continues par les
anglais disent que vous êtes perdus
qu'est ce que vous faites là ce que vous
savez vous êtes la meuf s'élève d'un
coup certaines chinois hélas non non non
non français et d'un coup la cuisine est
actif effet à temps mais également ils
sont enfin le dernier entre nous et la
loi il y avait les gens avant d'aller
ma cuisine allons gagner avec la boule
au ventre en mode qu'est ce que je vais
retrouver chez moi et en fait à l'arrêt
dans la chambre des enfants les enfants
dorment
j'attends des réponses données par ou
l'argent elle est complètement sans
dessus-dessous quoi j'aurai enfin la
prime plein de trucs et machins et
entre-temps donc elle appelle les flics
quand elles en ont eu pour leur dire bah
y'a une infusion chez moi et 9 qui est
là qui se croient chez elle qui a
défoncé la porte est la musique et des
photos fin trop bizarre quoi elle flics
sont arrivés ils ont un fils mba a fait
un pas de ses neuf qui pour les
conclusions de l'histoire était une
patiente à mon père il ya très longtemps
et en fait il est tombé éperdument
grenon perd pas beaucoup de lettres
d'amour machin super trio relief en 3d
là sur les enveloppes des seules où ça
finit là en droit elle a été embarquée
en hp et ses parents sont excusés pour
ce qui s'était passé et en fait elle a
fait un total est le valais a tempéré
qui sont sur notre photo que tu as dit
qu'il ressemble c'est drôle parce que du
coup elle s'est dit c'est peut-être la
chercher un doute
obama s'est fait le dos rond et laissé
pour compte
en fait ce truc là c'est horrible à
vivre parce que c' est bouleversé toute
intrusion la personne n'a touché à tes
affaires et où ses performances mais en
fait c'est une maladie dont j'ai oublié
le nom devrait un vrai syndrôme que
beaucoup beaucoup de gens ont faim et
surtout envers des big star il ya brad
pitt sérieuses après depuis productid la
u2 ou nous vient du mile-end valeur
voilà il ya beaucoup de grandes stars où
ils sont rentrés chez eux
il ya quelqu'un il a créé un cas là
genre menti je te fais à dîner ouais
tout est vraiment la star qui dit je te
connais pas je te connais pas en fait
sociales et humaines
bah ouais ouais si toi ta petite
histoire lucioles moi j'aimerais well
well as et moi c'est pas je sais pas
c'est creepy mais je pense qu'il ya un
élément qui fait que toute l'histoire le
devient en fait tu vois tu peux y aller
pas bon ça se passe en 2012 c'est noël
on est en famille étouffante
c'est noël quoi et ma mère elle sort une
vieille boîte avec des vieilles
cassettes vidéo parce que ma mère l
intox
vous vous depuis très longtemps elle
filme tout le temps h 24 du coup tu as
des du coup j'ai masse de souvenirs
mas de trucs de doran c'est trop bien
c'est le feu mais du coup elle sort
cette vieille boîte et où elle balance
des femmes et des cassettes et là sur
l'écran je me vois moi 4 5 ans très peu
de gens le savent mais je n'ai pas je
suis né en france j'ai pas vécu mais de
combien salles en france les ai vécus en
namibie
c'est au dessus de l'afrique du sud et
du coup j'ai grandi là bas et tout du
coup je me vois sur ces cassettes en
namibie 4 5 ans je cours partout ma
chère et où il ya mes parents il ya moi
et ma petite soeur est un mec qui est
toujours avec nous il est là il à
grosses mailles
c'est bizarre que vous l'imaginez un
petit peu ça renoir il s'appelle mon
gars c'est un mélange entre omar sy
étonnant que le mec tu vois genre très
bas
non mais vraiment voyait pas trop sympa
tout le temps là il est là pas que sur
une casquette il assure une vingtaine de
cassettes donc il est là sur plusieurs
mois tu as des souvenirs de lui il est
là il joue avec vos amis parle avec mon
père il mange avec nous et d'une
cassette à une autre il est plus là et
je me dis le mec enfin le gosse de 4 ou
5 ans qui est dans l'écran ils sont bas
les couilles il fait rien à [ __ ] ils
continuent à jouer mais le gars de 2012
donc le mois de 17 ans qui est devant
l'écran acquérir des cassettes je me dis
[ __ ] mais c'est chelou pourquoi il est
plus là tu vois bref je me sens dans un
coin de ma tête et huit mois plus tard
je suis avec mes potes et je dis à mes
potes [ __ ] c'est cool qu'on se barre
qu'on avait visité un petit peu jean
l'assaillant la plus l'école
non je crois j'ai commencé youtube en
plus à ce moment là j'avais je sais pas
j'ai un peu de thunes je voulais je
voulais qu'on se casse quelque part quoi
et du coup la destination qu'elle a
choisi celle de la mine parce que ça
faisait très longue place du coup je
n'étais pas retourné mois depuis et
c'est un pays que j'avais envie de
revoir et mes potes envie de le
découvrir et en plus il trouve que c'est
un des plus beaux pays du monde ont ces
ballons à midi on arrive là bas dans un
hôtel et où on lit les trous du cul
parce que du coup on joue à deux puces
solide année visitent la classe malgré
mes mecs en reste un mois dans la
chambre d'hôtel h plage oiseaux plus
alors qu alors le plus beau pays
la cbi avec 20 bref classique et un
moment se lève un matin on se lève tu
vois aussi [ __ ] dégâts seraient plus
qu'on ait visité quoi un petit peu au
mollet au moins aussi [ __ ] vas-y goût
en bouche quoi genre la meuf à l'accueil
et je lui dis voilà on aimerait bien
visiter le pays on aime bien bouger on
aimerait bien faire le tour de namibie
revenir à l'hôtel comme on peut
s'organiser qu'on peut faire et tout est
la meuf trop gentil 300 en libye sont
tous gentils commence à me dire à vous
en faites pas [ __ ] je connais un gars
qui s'appelle ce cas lampes et il est
trop cool et il va vous faire le tour il
est adorable chien et tout ça t'arrive
et là le lendemain on voit ce que l'on
peut arriver avec un vieux vannes
je soutiens les mêmes pneus crevés bref
et le mec il arrive c'est un mélange
entre omar sy et tendance il a imputé de
smile et je me dis mais toi je te
connais je le dis tu vois je sais pas
pourquoi il ya fini je n'ai pas du tout
de suite mais je vous il ya un truc
chelou entre toi et bref on fait le tour
d'un ami billy le voyage dure un mois
c'est pas avec ce gars à un mois avec ce
gars donc on attend vit dans des
bidonvilles en astronomie à partir des
fois t'es vraiment à larache mais il
s'investissait tellement il était
tellement cool tellement gentil que j'ai
kiffé mage qui fait ma race est ce
qu'être un des plus beaux voyages de ma
vie c'est comme ça incroyable et bref on
passe tous en ahl avec lui et sur le
chemin du retour il ya mes potes qui
sont dans le van derrière ils dorment
moi je suis devant avec lui et je me
tourne vers lui je disque à l'amp je
crois qu'on se connaît enfin je crois
pas qu'on s'est déjà vu machin est tout
n'diaye bah oui vous êtes le fils de
monsieur bout d'une demie seconde
famille voilà elle a choqué y est du
coup tu es au courant depuis le début
c'est ce que le connais tu me connais
tous tu dis rien du tout c'est chelou
mais c'est peut-être sa façon d'être ce
qu'il ne parle pas beaucoup et où tu
vois je me dis ok et je lui dis n'est
que c'est bizarre parce que noël dernier
je regardais les cassettes et où et
quand j'étais petit je te voyais dans ma
maison et tout en namibie stube wyeth
est avec nous et tout est d'une cassette
à une n'était plus là et il fait ok
c'est tout s'explique
la balle part mme habib sy le hockey
c'est en mode peint pas trop parce que
trop de questions qui fâchent d'or la
route est longue mais peut-être ai-je eu
bon bout j'ai fermé ma gueule je vais me
poser d'autres questions on arrive à
l'hôtel oppose deux affaires où l'usure
ouest où il a été trop gentil avec nous
tu vois ils sont dans la merde de
laquelle elle me dit alors si bien passé
avec ce qu'alain machin et tout c'est
cool
moi je dis ouais c'était trop cool ma
charge utile pourquoi vous l'appelez
scarpe s'appelle pascal amp et on me dit
non je sais même pas ce cap il s'appelle
un gars et je dis bien oui je sais
qu'ils s'appellent anga pourquoi
l'appeler ce calendrier parce que ce cas
là on abat en afrique année ça veut dire
voyous j'y vais pourquoi vous l'appelez
voyons on parle quand même de longueur
pour le calme de tendance m dibaba il a
quand même tué sa femme ok on pas là on
était bons hors murs là au parc sera
fait mi l'acide ouais je suis dit ouais
ouais là mais c'est les histoires et en
fait c'est une histoire qui est connue
là-bas et en gros j'ai fait savoir une
chose puis parenthèse dans la vie le
portail motorisé hongrie devait se
marier et la veille de son mariage
iron
lui il voit sa femme sur le canada avec
un autre mec il avait la gueule dans la
poche de colère il a buté le mec tu es
la femme du coup de fil par butelle mec
je dis ça comme ça je sais jeudi avec le
smile mais c'est vraiment nerveuse
d'accord mais je préfère un [ __ ] a
évidemment absolument dramatique et
voilà il se fait choper quinzaine de
tonnes fait que tu aies que fait que dix
ans parce que c'est pas on a milli et
moi du coup j'ai compris pourquoi on
garde les disparus des gazoducs des
mines etc
voilà ouais ces crimes passionnels et
c'est arrivé
malheureusement beaucoup de fois dans
l'est mais quand j'ai appris ça j'étais
en plus il est beau tout est là je leur
ai dit mais il y en a pas un qui croyait
pour que ce soit tu vois et c'est vrai
il s'avère que c'est vrai en fait en
fait c'est juste bouleversant qui a été
si proche d'un mec cassis a tué sa femme
c'est ça en fait c'est que je connais
personne dans ma vie personne d'autre
quelqu'un je suis très content à tous et
bien des amis est ce que cette édition
guest vous a plu oui moi je suis refait
moi je suis content aussi
bon je suis un peu déçu mais j'ai
compris pourquoi les gens aimaient bien
les vidéos seraient doha parce que là
j'étais un peu à la place des gens et
j'ai vraiment merci beaucoup d'être venu
leur parler de ça c'était vraiment cool
et puis à dénouer lens ça vous a plu
vous et des petites questions n'hésitez
pas je pense que les commentaires pas du
tout ils sont décrits accéder sans foot
allez je vous inscrire au prochain sera
une prochaine vidéo je tripe ont
tendance à trop bien
[Musique]